The Monaco MK arriving at rdam Port 33
days after departed from Malaysia more
than a week later than planned Dany
Shipping Company mesque decided to
divert The Vessel and dozens of others
to avoid possible attacks in the Red Sea
by houthi forces in Yemen containers
carrying food clothes computers and
Medicine eagerly awaited by buyers
forced to adjust their production
schedules a very important effect is
that the costs of Transport are
increasing um uh the container carriers
have increased their tariffs they have
introduced search charges related to the
disturbance uh at the moment uh but it
is also the the the value of time the
value of the cargo that is uh important
he estimates that for each container
ship carrying around 15,000 containers
the longer route will add around 16
million in additional costs houthi
Rebels have increased their attacks in
the Red Sea in recent weeks in
solidarity with people in Gaza demanding
Israel to stop its military campaign to
avoid the seis Canal some large shipping
companies are taking the near 6,000
kilomet longer Route Around the Cape of
Good Hope depending on the size of the
ships this means between 7 to 12 days
more travel time business in rdam Port
the main gateway to Europe had already
been slow due to decreased demand caused
by high inflation fewer container ships
means less business for Europe's largest
port with economies already slowing down
the crisis in the Red Sea is making them
worse and the longer the SE Canal
continues to be a dangerous route
between the East and the West the more
European economies will suffer the
Netherlands is the only EU country that
is part of the US Red Sea Coalition that
has performed air strikes on houthi
Targets in the past week the shippers
fear they now could become targets the
only thing that the nland did in the
Coalition is to protect that freedom of
navigation and that is what we stand for
it comes with a consequence and in that
perspective we ask our Dutch government
to please uh to enlarge the Coalition so
that the Dutch SE Faris and the Dutch
vessels are not being at risk anymore
ship owners have asked the government to
put pressure on other EU countries like
Germany or France to join the Coalition
too this crisis shows once again how
vulnerable international trade routes
have become and how Europe's economies
can easily be affected step fast in Al
jazer
rotam make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer